obviously there were so many unanswered
questions to last year's sleeper hit
sharknado that the sci-fi Network
decided to release a sequel sharknado 2
and this time they're bringing that
great white pot action not just to your
screen but also to your lamp's perhaps I
should explain this here is a Philips
cue light bulb and there are three
interesting things about it it's an LED
bulb you can actually generate any color
you want and it has built-in Wi-Fi so
you can control each bulb from an app on
your phone so what is sci-fi and flying
sharks have to do with all of this well
the network has taken advantage of the
hughes Wi-Fi connection to coordinate
the lighting in your room to the action
that's occurring in the movie Syfy's
second screen app sci-fi Sync can listen
for audio cues from the movie and then
send instructions to the bulbs in your
house so for example your room may be
cast in a very nice blue light when
you're out on the water but then turn a
shade of crimson red when some poor
sucker gets chomped by a makeup like
anything involving sharknado this is all
a bit silly okay more than a bit but the
implications are actually more
interesting than just creating a
lighting scheme for the latest I ins
earring Tara Reid vehicle up until about
now lights pretty much only did two
things they turned off and they turned
on but if you make lights smart and
colourful different apps can control
them in different ways
your lights could turn on automatically
when you wake up because your Fitbit
detects that you are moving play music
and the lights might sync up to the
beats of every song turning your house
into a disco right now a huge starter
kit cost around two hundred dollars and
individual bulbs run about sixty so
playing lighting designer doesn't come
cheap
two things are certain the price will
come down over time and there will most
definitely be a sharknado